foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
Tyler please welcome our sensor Gary
lineker compares the government and his
policy on migrants to Nazi Germany but
whether you agree with him or not and
I'll give my verdict should he be sacked
for expressing an honestly held opinion
International women's day but what's the
point celebrating it or even having it
where most of the people virtue thinking
about it today won't even say what a
woman is we'll debate that
plus how old is too old to run a country
two septuagenarian superstars Gene
Simmons a rock legend Jerry Springer the
Legend legend go head to head
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening for London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored happy
International women's day
hurray although personally as a more
Ardent feminist than all the virtue
signalers out there today
I celebrate it every day for me I'm a
365 day year feminist
not just one day a year not me
I'm every day
but what about this International
women's day anyway
what does it mean
we're in an era where people won't see
the word women they say things like
individuals with a cervix
persons who identify as female birthing
parents
menstruators chest feeders bodies with
vaginas and so on and so on
it's utter Madness but this is becoming
the norm these are all genuine terms
used to describe adult human females by
everyone from the British NHS to Milan
sit medical journal
now you might notice the problem with
this so-called inclusive language it
excludes women
and in these fevered times woman seems
to be the hardest word
can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can I provide a definition no yeah
I can't my question is are all trans
women women they haven't answered that
question well that's not the point that
we're dealing with yeah I like scented
candles I've watched Sex in the City
yeah how do I know if if I'm a woman
that's a great question woman can have a
penis
look I'm not but
what are they identifying as as a woman
what is that
as a woman
trans women are women but in the present
context there is no automatic right for
a trans woman there are context where a
trans women is not a woman no there is
as prime minister Rishi sune told me to
migrate relief and probably yours it's
not a difficult question a woman is an
adult human female
standing up for women has never been
more important women have fought for
years for the right to vote for equal
pay opportunities respect
but all those rights are now under
attack and the attacks range from the
ridiculous to the downright dangerous
this Ultra woke mentality that anyone
could be a woman who sticks their hand
up and says they're a woman at least if
people like sex offenders like Adam
Graham in Scotland who suddenly
identified as Isla Bryson at his trial
demanded a place in a female prison and
got one where if you've been allowed to
stay there he could have attacked other
women
eventually Common Sense prevailed
Nicholas sturgeon the first minister of
Scotland was forced to resign over the
Fallout from all this and he and I'm
afraid I use the word he in his case
he's a male rapist was sent back to a
male prison where he belonged even his
ex-wife said the whole thing was a total
scam to get a softer sentence
the Cambridge Dictionary is clear it's
an adult human female it's a biological
fact you can't muck around with Biology
it's also an adult who lives and
identifies as female that they may have
been said to be have a different sex at
Birth
well some girls schools will no longer
call their pupils girls on the off
chance that the girls identify as one of
the other seven and a half thousand
genders we're not supposed to accept
Sports women who've dedicated their
lives to achieving excellence in their
fields find themselves competing against
in any case losing to people who were
born male
the brittle walls as I and many others
warned erased gendered categories to
appease The Virtue signalers and women
were properly expunged from the top
category not a single woman in the best
artist category exactly what I said
would happen
ironically given the subject matter the
world has gone nuts
women used to be called women before
trans activists made it a verbal hate
crime punishable by instant cancellation
it's not about trans right I support
trans people's rights to fairness and
equality as I always say not when it
impinges and infringes and destroys
women's rights to fairness and equality
so I say we should just get rid of
international women's day I think it's
become a fast until all those queuing up
to Signal their virtue about it are
prepared to say in public what a woman
is otherwise what are we celebrating
and how can we use the word women in the
title of a day we're supposed to
celebrate when those who want to
celebrate it refuse to say what one is
well join me now is the author and
commentator Angelica Mallet talk TVs
Esther Krakow and Fox News contributor
Tommy Lawrence the Tommy layering let me
start with you too two people in Britain
today
who've been at the Forefront of not
saying what a woman is one is Nicholas
sturgeon the ex first minister of
Scotland who lost her job because of
this ridiculous fast of a rapist
self-identifying
um she tweeted at a proud and
international women's day to visit my
old University of Glasgow and banged on
about women's rights this is the woman
who just literally lost her job for
allowing a male rapist into a female
prison and to kill star moves literally
the opposition labor party here was
talking about protections for women in
Parliament today and yet he refuses to
say what a woman is where are we with
this how has it come that leaders of
parties in countries like the UK and we
see a lot of it in America as well just
won't say what a woman is
well first of all I have to apologize to
you because all of this wokeness
originates here in the United States of
America and then we export it to you in
the U.S yes we started this really in in
America yes we are you know the wokeness
starts here and then it of course moves
over and now you guys have to deal with
it the world has to deal with it but I
say this I'm proud to celebrate
International women's day because I know
what a woman is so I would say if you
don't know what a woman is you don't get
to celebrate it you don't get to pretend
to be a feminist when it's helpful to
you or helpful to your political
narrative you have to be able to Define
what a woman is this is all of farce
they are seeking to erase women and this
is the radical rainbow Mafia as I call
it this is not your average LGBT
activist this is the rainbow Mafia
section of that radical lgbtq movement
that has made women less than and then
has elevated all of this transgenderism
and all of this pickier gender identify
as potato they have hijacked the women's
rights movement the feminist movement
and actual feminists should be really
pissed off about it well as a feminist I
am um I recently interviewed Angelica
the Prime Minister Rishi sunak and I
asked him this question which seems to
stump many other leaders here's the clip
what is a woman
we know that Nicholas sturgeon can't
answer that we know kirst armor can't
answer that you're the British prime
minister what is a woman yeah I of
course I know a woman adult human female
it's not difficult is it Angelica I mean
that is what a woman is I mean I don't
know why you're obsessed with defining
it like what what is a man like why do
we need these arbitrary a man is a male
adult human I mean that's it right okay
I don't know that we need these are just
biological facts but they're just facts
they're not they're not arguable points
are they but you I think we have a right
to self-identify and you said you want
to as well I'd like to be a woman you
can identify as a woman I don't know why
there is such an issue around we've
literally just seen a male rapist use
that scam to get himself put into a
female prison where he could attack
vulnerable women inside a female prison
when even his ex-wife said it was all a
scam which is a terrible very
distressing isolated incident and I
think it's easy to take that and say
that means that no no one can identify
as a woman
but it's it's 42 of trans identifying
prisoners in prison are in there for sex
crimes there's actually an advantage
evidently to identifying as a female
because they never identify as male
because somehow milk doesn't seem less
appealing to them it's really weird
anyways
this self-identity
totally Limitless when you're talking
about International women's day I don't
know why we take the the conversation
around International Wednesday and make
it about this but if anyone has so many
best but if anyone according to you can
identify as a woman anyone can right
I don't see a problem to literally put
the hand up and say I'm a woman but it's
not an easy thing to do to go out it's
very easy you might think it's easy to
say but to decide to do that to say what
is doing involved whatever that person
decides and say I I don't identify as
perhaps the sector so why can't I
identify okay why can't I identify as a
black lesbian ah well firstly I mean I'm
serious I'm serious if I can identify as
anything without any need to prove I'm
actually what that is I I why can't I on
International women's day say I'm Piers
Morgan I'm a black lesbian I think
taking it to a kind of absurd moment I
think that's something with respect I
think that you've already opened the
absurdity door by saying it is Limitless
you can do what you like anyone can say
I'm a woman so I simply ask you why
can't I I mean this point kind of
ridicules trans people to an acceptance
actually what you said ridicules trans
people because actually people who who
go through the full process of
transition who actually go through what
we used to call as sex change which I
don't think you can Muck around with
original biology but those who actually
go through surgical procedure of them a
number of years I've got great respect
for that very difficult Journey they go
on I have zero respect for people who
just Wallop their hand up and go
suddenly I'm a woman and I want all the
rights that a woman has and I want to
compete say in sport I'm a six foot four
and French athletes Sprinter swimmer
whatever who's competed very
mediocreally in male sport I now want to
come in and Crush women in swimming
pools and in sprinting events and break
all their records perhaps irrevocably
just by saying I'm a woman I think that
is the absurdity you were talking about
my response was to say well if it's
Limitless why can't I then say whatever
I want to say and you say immediately as
I knew you would well that's ridiculous
but my point is you have been ridiculous
well that's your opinion you can think
I'm ridiculous but I don't think you can
say Well it has I don't know why I am
but you're not you're I don't think you
have to say it's post-op is the only way
that someone's allowed to identify the
original standard for us to the original
standard for being transgender was being
diagnosed with gender dysphoria which is
a legitimate condition and now it's been
oh however way you feel so if you feel
on Tuesday you're a woman and on
Thursday you're a pizza that's perfectly
valid but to you that's ridiculous and I
want to know why that is ridiculous we
should be talking about actual women on
International women's day that's not
crazy I mean I agree I think but your
idea of an actual woman is an adult
female it's not different chromosomes
are a pretty good indication I don't
think you have to be biologically female
to identify then you are wrong because
then I can identify as a fox
yeah but again it's kind of an absurd
Point how many well let me ask you this
let me ask you this Angelica how many
genders are there
two there are two genders oh wow so you
don't believe in transgenders at all
well I think I think they're well hey
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa there are two
genders well it's taught well if you say
well you've literally just launched this
huge defense of transgenderism now
you've eradicated it I think there's
there are two genders you mean male and
female right there's gender fluidity I
will fluid between what between what
between different identities and we can
choose you see how difficult this is
though but it is difficult but I think
maybe but it's not difficult until you
make it difficult you see the BBC has
done teaching videos so 11 and 12 year
olds where they say there are a hundred
genders one of them was astragender
which is an affinity with the Stars on
the Galaxy my response to that on the
last show I did was to say well in that
case I identifies a two-spirit penguin I
was then told I was being ridiculous but
I made the same point the Ridiculousness
is the BBC teaching kids there are a
hundred genders there aren't it is
absurd bring back Tommy lahren who I
imagine is hyperventilating over there
okay um Tommy I mean look I don't see
why if it's Limitless I can't just say
I'm Piers Morgan I'm a black lesbian
because that is where Limitless
self-identity takes this it means that
male rapists can say they're women and
get into into female prisons it means I
can say I'm a two-spirit penguin or a
black lesbian and why can't I because
that is where it takes you
well it certainly does and I think you
just had the perfect argument there it's
impossible to Define and it's impossible
to stand up for because it's a mockery
of what actual people are and
furthermore going back to children when
this happens at a young age when you
start trying to convince kids that they
don't know what gender they are they're
born in the wrong body at two three four
five six seven eight nine ten years old
that's child abuse all right gender
affirming care wherein you only tell
somebody they can be whatever they want
to be regardless of their biology at a
young age that is child abuse it's
happening in the UK it's happening in
the U.S and this is making room for
groomers to groom young people to
confuse the heck out of them make them
not know what they are so they can take
advantage and exploit them now I want to
be very clear here this is not the
mainstream LGBT key movement there are a
lot of conservatives that even support
that movement this is a radical agenda
made by groomers and they don't want you
to call them groomers which is a perfect
example of why they are groomers this is
what we're doing is to confuse young
people to confuse all people to make
them dumber and make them confuse as to
what they are it's a mockery of women's
rights actually the mockery of Human
Rights yeah and we should no longer be
having and you end up with scandals like
the Tavistock Clinic here in London in
the UK where they were basically
mutilating children young you know kids
teenagers mutilating their bodies
irrevocably and then it turned out after
it closed after a scandalous report came
out but 97 of all the patients had other
conditions from autism to depression to
other issues which may have been
affecting their ability to think
straight about what they wanted to be
and that was to me as a father of four
kids utterly horrific just horrific that
this was going on and anyone who tried
to raise concerns about this and
journalists did were immediately branded
transphobic and Esther this comes back
to what we see with you know people like
JK Rowling who's I'm no friend of JK
rally she can't stand me and I don't
like her right we it's like fire and
water but I on this issue I've not seen
a word she said that is transphobic I've
just heard her go I want to support and
protect women's rights for that she's
been unbelievably hounded abused
attempts to cancel which fortunately had
backfired but it's all wrong this isn't
it but the thing is and one of the
shocking things that she's been attacked
for is for drawing attention to
domestic violence and violence against
women and that's actually the biggest
Point here other than the fact that you
know that male rapist was allowed to go
into a female prison in Scotland there's
a genuine danger about around allowing
men into women's spaces like women's
shelters and things like that and they
can be there just by identifying as a
woman and then identifying as a tree the
next day I mean do you understand that
part of the argument I understand that
kind of the argument but I I mean like
Tommy said I don't think this is
confusing for children I think it's
giving you freedom of expression and
freedom of choice how many girls did you
know like my wife was a bit of a tomboy
when she was young right how many kids
do you know young girls in particular
who are tomboys but if the wrong person
gets hold of them and persuades them
actually what you should start doing is
mutilating your body and have a full
attempt to become a boy that's not what
most tomboys end up wanting they end up
actually going through puberty getting
older and then that's it they've become
women right but if you get hold of these
impress young minds too early when
they're just Clowning Around being
tomboys that's the danger to me I don't
think the messaging is as Extreme as you
as you think it is and I think we think
it was pretty extreme I think we whip
ourselves into a frenzy thinking uh
thinking these things and this language
that you mentioned at the start of the
show I don't think you hear that
language used that often in like
everyday speech which language I think
what you were saying um I know these are
all NHS websites I know this is where
you're wrong this is actually NHS
websites in many cases they genuinely
call women chest feeders birthing
Partners they dare not say anything
gender specific to women in case some
trans people don't like it to which I
say where are the rights of women to be
cool what they want to be called why
does all language have to be degendered
for a tiny minority of people I think
the problem is there's so much fear
around having these kind of
conversations and saying the wrong thing
getting it wrong that means that people
can't have conversations that feel kind
of progressive about what what is gender
identity what does the future look like
how do we create a compassionate space
so so I think to your questions start
like what is women and why politicians
wouldn't answer it they're so scared of
getting it wrong and people are scared
because they they gives the the mob come
for them exactly and the mob needs to
just go away and shut up anyway I think
scrap International women's day until we
can all agree what a woman is no I'm
sorry I think there's so many benefits
to having International women's day it
would be a real shame to do that well if
you're in your way everyone was
celebrated by identifying as a woman
even if they weren't well bangalam happy
International women's day I am a woman
it's a false anyway Angelica lovely to
see you thank you very much I'm still
going to see you a bit later on Tommy
always good to have you over at the pond
International women's day there you are
a fine example of a genuine woman great
thank you yes absolutely identify as a
woman I am a woman and that's how this
thing works ladies and gentlemen exactly
thank you Tommy Lara well next tonight
MPS demand that Gary lineker sporting
Legend uh is fired from the BBC office
comparing the government's migrant
policy to Nazi Germany it is entitled to
share his opinions we'll debate that
with his former colleague Mark lawrenson
next
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7 pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
thank you
well still to come to life possibly the
greatest panel ever ascended to debate
how old is too old to be a world leader
to septuagenarian Superstars Gene
Simmons from Cass and Jerry Springer TV
icon will join me live and go head to
head
the first the match of the day star Gary
lineker former England striker of course
has face down demands from MPS it should
be fired for condemning the government's
migrant policy well in response to a
video of Homer secretary swella bravaman
explaining the scheme then it had
tweeted good Heavens this is beyond
awful it went on to say there is no huge
influx we take far fewer refugees and
other major European countries it's just
an intolerable immeasurably cruel policy
dictator the most vulnerable people in
language that is not dissimilar to that
used by Germany in the 30s and I'm out
of order
it's an interesting debate this my view
is it's clearly incendiary what Gary
denick has said and historic
historically wrong I think there's no
comparison between what this current
British government is proposing to what
Nazi Germany did Gary got a bit carried
away as he tends to do we have dinner
together quite regularly and this is
what he does and he would say the same
about me we both have strong opinions we
both believe in what we say and we
express them forcefully but we agree to
disagree and I have no problem with Gary
lineker a football presenter Sports
presenter from giving his views he's not
a BBC News journalist he's not anchoring
the news at 10 or question time or news
night he's a football presenter doing
much of a day another major sporting
events he's a celebrity in a public
figure people want to know is eight and
a half million followers want to know
what he thinks about stuff why do we
pretend that people like him exist in a
sealed BBC bubble a perfect propriety
where no opinions exist I know many BBC
journalists they're all highly
opinionated but the ones that work in
news understand the importance of
impartiality who cares what Gary denica
really says about government policy on
stuff it's just in the end a football
presenter I don't mean that to denigrate
it means it's very good at it but he's
not a news presenter so it shouldn't
matter to the BBC's news output what he
thinks about the migrant situation now
we said this on Match of the day then
the criticism would be justified I for
example did not like him making his
start of the World Cup coverage a
monologue about qatar's human rights
abuses because he hadn't done it before
in previous World Cups in other
countries not least Russia and I very
much doubt he'll do it at the next one
in America so I felt it was wrong to
single out cats and also it Blended
politics and football in that case but
my question then for the BBC would be if
it was all right for Gary lineker to
express his views about qatar's human
rights abuses and you put him up to
doing it and agreed that he could do
that wanted him to well what's the
difference between him doing that at the
start of a World Cup and now tweeting
his disagreement about what he considers
human rights abuses by the current
British government
now if you decide not to watch him
because of opinions that's his right
but I don't think you can be a
campaigner for free speech as I am and
just turn off the tap because I don't
like the opinion I'm hearing
if little kid was cheering the
government for getting the grips of the
migrant crisis the very people now
demanding you be fired would be wanting
him to get a statue in Trafalgar Square
to me is linika's former match of the
day co-star Mark Lawrence and also
joined by dailymore is associated to
Kevin McGuire and Esther cracker is
still with me so Mark Lawrence
what is your honest view about this it's
the latest in many run-ins that Gary's
had over his political tweets on his own
Twitter account so not on television or
match of the day but do you think it
crosses a line
well first of all peers I'm a pint of
Guinness if you're interested and
secondly look look it's it's it's up to
him if he he wants to say what he wants
to say I mean the use in terms of in
relation talking about the Nazis was
absolutely totally wrong but it's a
human being he's bright you know he's
bright as well he's allowed to say what
he wants to say and it's frightening at
the moment and everybody all of a sudden
is saying you've got to suck him why
have you got to suck him we've all got a
right to say what we want to say have we
not is the problem Mark I don't know
what guidance you were given when you
worked for the BBC for so long but is
the problem that the BBC themselves
haven't really drawn the line they
haven't really clarified this situation
where if a news and current affairs uh
presenter does something like this
everybody knows that crosses a line but
it hasn't really been said publicly what
the line is in relation to people like
you when you work there or Gary and
again is that part of the problem well
were you told specifically you can't do
this kind of thing
no no you're not told at all
um and obviously you know you because if
you've got any modicum of common sense
you know exactly what you need to say at
the at the given moment but no there's
there's no I mean the the problem is
they are frightened to death of their
own Shadows the BBC that is the Crux of
the matter and therefore every time
somebody goes on on television obviously
on the radio whatever or what Gary said
in terms of the Tweet they are wetting
themselves because they just do not know
and they say no he's gonna we're gonna
wrap him over the knuckles you're not
gonna sack Gary lanika for what he said
you may totally disagree and I agree
disagree with what he said anyway but
there's no way you're gonna sack him is
there well apart for anything else one
of the people would have to authorize
his sacking would be Richard Sharp the
chairman who gave 400 000 pounds to the
conservative party and also helped Boris
Johnson get a loan of 800 000. is he
really gonna sack a presenter in
partiality issues because I think that
would be a pretty hard sell now I guess
what I would say on the BBC side I know
a lot of BBC presenters and they do take
the news ones the the
impartiality principle incredibly
seriously and a lot of them are
genuinely angry that Gary seems to be
able to get away with saying whatever he
likes to a very large number of people
to his eight and a half million
followers they believe it then backfires
on their ability in the news division to
genuinely say that the whole Corporation
is impartial
but but fears is is saying it as as a
person
not as a match of the day sport
presenter whatever you want to describe
him as he's just saying it as a human
being I think it's different if you're
involved with the news which which it
has to be but he's just as you say for
you know an old an old England scorer
and that's what he is that's as good as
he is as a presenter that's that's
basically the bottom of the bottom of it
all yeah Kevin I mean I this is my thing
I thought I felt the analogy he drew was
completely wrong actually quite
offensive to anyone who went through the
Holocaust if you're Jewish and you read
this try to try to compare What's
Happening Now sending people back who
come up on shore on a dinghy to anything
the Nazis did in Exterminating 12
million people 6 million of which were
Jewish that analogy seemed to me to be
completely wrong yeah but what he was
doing appears he wasn't saying the
government's setting up concentration
camps he was actually echoing uh Joan
Salter who's a British Holocaust
Survivor who earlier this year said what
the government is doing is dehumanizing
people and this is what happened in
Germany people were dehumanized first
and then you go somewhere else so he's
not saying there putting people in gas
so you think he was more a clumsy
analogy there is a clumsiness in it but
it's the dehumanization and not treating
them as people yes so the problem is I
think whenever the moment you evoke
Adolf Hitler or the nuts yes unless
you're literally talking about people
who've murdered millions and millions of
people it never ever works it's always
extremely important the wrong analogy
it's an extremely poor taste I have an
issue with this because why does he
never draw parallels with the Rwandan
Genocide for example or what happened in
Cambodia why is it always Nazi Germany
and Adolf Hitler Hitler and the Nazis
because it's because it's Western Europe
and we're in Western Europe there's a
disregard there is a disregard there for
for the Jewish communities in this
country that actually have a history
attached to that and I think that's what
it comes to a lot of Jewish people today
on the Airways were upset the Holocaust
was more than just Jewish people or six
million numbers were absolutely Central
they're also Romani gypsies trade unions
Communists
no no but that's it's you can you can
claim there's an over Western focus in
Western Union this principle of
impartiality I mean Emily Maitland has
basically left the BBC over a fury
involving amongst other things
retweeting me yeah about Dominic
Cummings who was just a blatant liar uh
taking the public for a ride about
Barnard castle and eyesight and so on
and she reflected that accurately and
the furore I think helped drive around
the BBC so they do take it very
seriously and they they see what
happened to someone like Emily and we
see a double standard applied now she
doesn't she thinks he should be allowed
to have his age she was tweeting that
today but look they appears the BBC is
having a crisis of confidence because
it's under such assault because of its
Central position funded by a license fee
that you have to you have to pay but if
you if you buy this idea it's a hotbed
of lefties you'd have to explain how did
David Cameron press secretary come from
BBC people did foreign
are not biased right and I don't I don't
think it's biased particularly in One
Direction but there's no such thing as
impartial journalism it's impossible it
attempts to be sometimes it's over it's
over in part as it was as it was on
climate change on brexit the final
question Esther should he get fired for
this absolutely not no no and Mark I
presume you don't think you should
either
absolutely not more importantly Mark
Before I Let You Go are Arsenal going to
win the league no Arsenal are not going
to win the league
listen listen we'll have you twittering
and twittering on about it for three
months when the season finishes
but because of your refusing to admit
the inevitable I'm gonna fire you from
this program tonight mark lawrenson
You're Fired thank you great to see you
good to see you guys see you later on uh
next tonight how old is too old to be a
world leader I'll be debating that with
kiss Legend Gene Simmons who's now
embarking on kiss's final tour and TV
Legend Jerry Springer who will never
ever stop working it's the greatest
panel ever assembled look at that two
icons in their fields they'll be live
next
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no with the people's
Channel nowhere to use every little
helps for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7 pm join me just
do it well that one too
[Music]
this is talk TV
for Donald Trump age 76 remains a
front-runner to be the Republican
nominee at next year's presidential
election aged 80 Joe Biden is already
the oldest president in American history
if he runs again and wins he'd be 86 by
the time his second term ends in 2028
he's already saying things like this
this week
I came back from a trip after being away
for a couple of days and I had these
terrible headaches was diagnosed with
having a
well anyway
they had to take the top of my head off
a couple times see if I had a brain
that's comforting isn't it that's the
president of the United States this week
um is it any wonder the concerns about
Biden's age top list of reasons Democrat
voters want the party to find an
alternative candidate for 2024. well
joining me now are legendary kiss front
man Gene Simmons who's just announced
dates for one final World Tour legendary
former talk show host uh ex Mayor of
Cincinnati and current TV icon because
that never gets taken away Jerry
Springer well welcome to both of you uh
like I say greatest panel ever assembled
Gene Simmons
um you're 73 I believe and you've
decided to end things with kiss in terms
of touring is that an age-related
decision by the band
well yes it is you know part and parcel
of being around for 50 years longer than
you've been alive young man we've been
touring we've been touring since the
last century literally speaking and at a
certain point pride self-respect and
everything says get off the stage so at
73 years of age right now still have
hair much more on my back unfortunately
the physicality just gets in the way I
mean we're not Blues performers we don't
stand still and just strum acoustic
guitar I wear Dragon boots that have the
weight of a bowling ball about 40 pounds
in all got to spit fire flying through
the air at a certain at a certain point
self-respect says be grateful thankful
and get off the stage and do you think
Gene should the same logic apply to
presidents I mean if Biden he's already
80. he'd be 86 if he was to run again
and win and he's already showing signs
many people think of yeah first onset a
set of dementia should he be able to run
as president of this age
no I don't think so and that doesn't
mean that I agree or don't agree with
the politics politics aside there should
be a test to find out if somebody has
their their wits about them number one
you're talking about the most powerful
person on Earth and also to find out
whether or not somebody is absolutely
nuts
there should be a qualification a
medical qualification and psychological
qualification that somebody in charge
isn't just going to go nuts and go like
that or fall down the stairs when they
try to go up on Air Force One okay let
me bringing uh Jerry on this because
Nikki Haley is one of the other
Republican uh candidates she actually
did say something very similar here's
what she said
in the America I see the permanent
politician will finally retire
[Applause]
we'll have term limits for congress
and mandatory mental competency tests
for politicians over 75 years old
[Applause]
Jerry you were about 15 when you were
married Cincinnati from memory it was a
very long time ago but you're a young
man don't these jobs require a certain
degree of mental agility uh certainly
we're showing a country like America
which you would think that every year
after 80 you're probably losing your
powers right
well first of all if we had a mental
acuity test uh for people who are going
to be president we never would have had
Trump uh there are a whole bunch of
other people that aren't older you know
uh
so that that issue I I put aside Biden
is an exceptional case now the we can
discuss whether he's too old to be
president but the fact of the matter is
the only person that actually knows that
for a fact
is the person or persons who examined
him everyone else just has an opinion
he's being tested whether or not he has
those facilities now the question is
when I look at the evidence this man in
two and a half years has accomplished
more than any American president since
Franklin Roosevelt with a possible
exception of Lyndon Johnson on domestic
policies now a lot of people don't like
what he's done but when you take a look
at the things that he's accomplished
this is not a man with dementia lowering
Healthcare inflation reduction these
wonderful things questioning that listen
I understand as a Democrat you think
they're all wonderful a lot of
Republicans think he's done a series of
terrible things but but there's no doubt
there's no doubt the midterm election
results for example were in some way a
validation of Biden's presidency so far
it was a lot better than people thought
might happen my question when you see
him do that clip this week where he
talks about him taking off the top of
his head to see if he has a brain a
mumbling
trying to make a silly
no he started a joke and halfway through
it realized this thing is falling flat
trust me I've been there so that's yeah
Jerry how old are you now have you don't
mind me asking
I'm 79 right and you've never stopped
working I know that your leather stop
working right
well I might but it
I think I still have my mental acuity I
think I may stop because there are the
things I want to do I want to spend more
time with Richard my grandson and follow
him in baseball and basketball and do
things like that so it's more that
decision more than a medical decision
here's what I believe is happening
overwhelmingly every poll shows
that the vast majority of people who
think Biden is too old or conservative
and Republican now there are Democrats
who think he's too old but when you ask
them why they think he's too old is they
worry that if he's at the top of the
ballot other people will think he's too
old and the ballot and and their whole
ticket will go down the drain that's a
political worry but if you're asking the
question is he competent to be president
of the United States there is absolutely
no evidence on his record so far
I can see I can see Gene wanting to get
back in here Gene
sorry look let's call it let's call it
for what it is
um I'm on both sides of the fence about
all sorts of political issues so you
can't call me a rabid Democrat or
conservative or liberal or any of that
you know I'm everybody's worst enemy
because I simply vote on the issues but
let's call it the way it is the masses I
don't believe for a second vote on
political platform they wouldn't be able
to explain to you anything it is
invariably and intrinsically another big
words like gymnasium the cult of
personality when people saw when people
saw Nixon with his five o'clock shadow
before any of you were born it was a TV
and sweating debate between Kennedy yeah
and Nixon and he had the five o'clock
shadow nobody remembers what they stood
for or who was a Democrat they just
didn't like that guy who looked like uh
you know Uncle Joe who's drinking a
little too much he just didn't look so
so when people watch Mr Trump who both
know they have their perception and when
people watch Mr Biden and we've all seen
him on TV and stuff unfortunately
sometimes turning around to shake hands
with people who aren't there or uh
mumbling words that doesn't mean I agree
or don't agree with the politics people
will judge this following political
uh battle based on personality I have
not met regular people who've been able
to explain to me what the different
political platforms are so I believe Mr
Button is in deep trouble I just want to
say one one last thing very quickly if I
was on the other side Mr Trump's side
and I may not be actually I have lots of
problems with him somebody is going to
put together a greatest hits of Mr Biden
falling off bicycles falling on stairs
and not even talk about politics not
even talk about politics and that person
can you imagine but can you imagine yeah
Jerry let me just say to you I think I
think the bigger the bigger problem
Jerry for Democrats I think is not
really Trump who remains the bogeyman
that may get out the Democrat vote Ash
has it happened last time so that might
be the worst scenario for the
Republicans if Trump does win the
nomination but if it's someone like
Governor Ron DeSantis who's in his 40s
full of energy full of dynamism you know
on a tough campaign Trail I would not
want to be a Democrat trying to have
Biden is my guy against a bloke half his
age with that kind of energy just purely
let me see this Gene just mentioned okay
let me just say this I absolutely agree
with you that there would be a political
burden with Biden at the top of the
ticket I totally recognize that
but I'm on the show because the question
was is Biden too old to be president
yeah on that issue he is not too old
based on his performance
is there a political price to pay
absolutely so Gene I have no argument
with what you just said I agree with you
totally but the issue is is he too old
objectively in his case I'm not saying
another 84 year old or 82 year old I'm
saying him I'm saying objective well I
know people
other than YouTube who bursts with
radiant vitality and Youthful dynamism I
know people like Dame Joan Collins who's
nearly 90 and is like a 50 year old you
know Warren Buffett people like this are
in the 90s still as sharp as a whip
there are lots of people I know who are
in their late 80s 90s who are incredibly
on it my issue with Biden is when you
see all these gaffs and all these
stumbles and everything else he looks to
me like he's already feeling his age at
80 and that would be a concern for me
but anyway guys I've got to leave it
there Jerry brilliant to see you again
we work together on America's Got Talent
and Gene great to see you we were
together on Celebrity Apprentice I and
thank God you pulled out after a few
episodes because that allowed me to win
because I think if you'd stayed in I'd
have been dead man so thank you Gene
Simmons for your selfless Act
great to see you guys take care
what next tonight uh we may have
mentioned this yesterday we're gonna
wallow in it a bit more we won an award
on this program a scoop of the year at
the British sports Oscars and we're
gonna boast about it after the break
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
will be discussing whether the BBC
should take action over Gary lineker's
outspoken tweets and we'll have all the
details on the senior Royals who seem to
snub Megan and Harry's invitation to
Princess Lily Betts christening and his
International women's day achieve
anything we're discussing all of that
and more at nine
[Music]
well welcome back I've still got Kevin
and Esther but I'll take a little moment
to wallow in a little bit of Triumph for
the show uh the Ronaldo interview that
we did which of course went around the
world and led to a lot of consequences
he left Manchester United went to Saudi
Arabia and all the fall that that
preceded that so we won scuba the year
at the British sports journalism Awards
which are the kind of the Oscars of
British sports journalism it was a great
honor to win that I have to say I wanted
to be a sports journalist when I was a
young kid so there's our award and
here's a little Montage of why we want
it with a little bit of what I said
about it on stage after the award was
given to me
Sir Alex Ferguson left a big gap in the
club not people forget that I'm human
human being that I passed through a
difficult moment now your baby dude is
in hospital kind of that didn't believe
why I felt uh provoked by the coach I
think that the empathy with the coach is
not good I think you don't you don't
respect the way I should deserve it's
hard it's hard for me to say that I will
not be back to Manchester United but
regardless as you say it's it's let's
see what's going to happen well I'd like
to thank Cristiano Ronaldo
until yesterday evening was the most
iconic number seven in Manchester United
history
I'm sure I speak for the whole room here
indisputably the greatest footballer of
all time
is also a man of his word and a really
good guy and I want to thank him because
without him I wouldn't be here there'd
be no scoop so thank you Cristiano
[Applause]
well there we have it so the the seven
nil gag obviously went down well with
those who got it but not so well with
man united fans uh but I sincere thanks
to Cristiano because without him there
wouldn't have been any scoop and it was
an amazing thing to be involved with and
I feel very proud of uh the interview
and also of the team here at Piers
Morgan on censored and talk TV who
helped get it on air and go around the
world it was a thunderous scoop and it
didn't cost us a penny so they're the
best ones so thank you all very much
let's turn to something else
um Catherine Ryan The Comedian says
about Leonardo DiCaprio dating young
ladies I don't think it's controversial
to say it's gross
now is she right is he getting creepy
that DiCaprio keeps dating when
apparently get to 25 that's the color
point I don't have to go as he heads to
50 or is there a double standard because
Madonna keeps prancing around with young
toy boys yeah she doesn't get anything
like the aggravation he gets I don't
think I don't think it's gross because
it is not a secret that men like young
beautiful attractive women I think it's
gross that the women who are clearly not
attracted to Leonardo DiCaprio because
he is very not attractive are just doing
it very clearly for his money now with
Madonna dating toy boys we can all
assume that she's not all there anyway
because she keeps showing us pictures of
her bum and her face now looks like a
loaf of Warburton what do you think is
it any of any of our businesses I find
the Madonna think a total cringe yeah uh
but I also find it's slightly cringy
DiCaprio that it's all the women are
always very young it's like well really
I still have your own Angels what do
they talk about I find DiCaprio creepy
actually
going out with people you know easily
young enough to be his uh you know his
daughter or in some cases probably
you're quite right there might be some
double standards with me because I've
criticized you for having a pop-up
Madonna be before maybe we should get
Madonna and DiCaprio together and then
we'll just solve all the problems she's
about 35 years too old yeah could you
imagine look I'm not all of her I think
I think most men if they're honest with
themselves they could debut we know the
French they would the French thing is
half a man's age plus seven is the
optimum age so if he's 50 the woman can
be 32. yes that's it apparently that's
the French word they seem to know about
these things
good night
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa